so we've been tracking the rise of
coronavirus cases in the United States
and we started seeing the numbers spiked
on June 19th there was the idea in late
April early May that that was the peak
when we had 30,000 new cases a day in
April May we were hoping I guess I mean
I certainly was hoping that we were past
the peak at least the waveone peak and
it looked like maybe we were until July
June 19th when we started seeing cases
climb and climb and climb up to as many
as 60,000 new cases a day a few days ago
centered around California and a bunch
of red states including Arizona Florida
and Texas at the top of that list and
what we observed for the last 20 or so
days was that even though the cases were
spiking the deaths were staying pretty
low and you can see if you're looking
that at the chart of deaths
they've been trending down and all along
there were questions about how is this
possible what's going on now the most
obvious explanation maybe we would call
it the simplest explanation we could say
the explanation that requires the fewest
assumptions is that there's simply a lag
between cases and deaths
you don't die the day you're diagnosed
so when you see cases spike you would
expect that it would take some time
before those increased case numbers turn
into deaths there were other
explanations that we considered as well
is it possible that the virus has
mutated to be less deadly it's possible
we didn't have any evidence for it is it
possible that doctors are getting better
at treating coronavirus patients which
is decreasing the death rate certainly
possible could it be that more testing
means healthier people are getting
tested so even though you have more
cases the share of cases that are
serious could be declining and that's
why the deaths continue to trend down or
is it younger people getting coronavirus
who are less likely to get really sick
all of these are reasonable
possibilities to wonder about but if the
explanation is the first one which is
there's a lag between cases and deaths
we would expect that somewhere in the
range of 18 to 21 days after the cases
spike deaths would start to spike
18 to 21 days from the start of the case
spike is this week it's yesterday it's
today it's tomorrow and sadly tragically
yesterday Arizona and Texas both hit
single day death records dating all the
way back to the start of the pandemic
yesterday we had again nearly 60,000 new
cases of corona virus reported and
deaths in Arizona and Texas and by the
way also in California California is not
exempt from this but it's been mostly
the red Staters saying that it's Arizona
and Texas that weren't going to see the
death spike
they are spiking Arizona with a hundred
and seventeen deaths yesterday Texas
with eighty four deaths yesterday those
are sad these are not records we want to
be setting these are tragic new high
marks for coronavirus deaths in a single
day now I don't want to be alarmist and
I hope that I'm wrong and I believe that
I've been relatively sober in my
analysis of coronavirus from the start
the simplest explanation is that the
deaths are spiking because the cases
spiked 20 days ago and if that's the
case in another 10 days the death
numbers are going to look really really
bad and what I mean by that is cases
started to spike on June 19 so the small
spike in deaths were seeing now would be
related to the start of the spike in
cases on June 19th around July 1st the
new case numbers were dramatically
higher than on June 19th and if that
tracks as a leading indicator to
eventual deaths in another 10 or 15 days
we are going to have unconscionable
numbers coming out of some of these
states it's horrible when we're right
about terrible things and this is really
really terrible now if we want to find
something to look at that looks okay
there are still some states doing quite
well right now the states with the
lowest reproduction rate of the virus
are Connecticut Washington DC which is
not a state Maine New Hampshire
Massachusetts Rhode Island Maryland and
Utah
although the reproduction rate there
what's called the R
or the r0 it's it's starting to creep up
and what I believe is going on is
nothing that requires any kind of
particular insight the states that are
doing well can only hold off cases for
so long if other states are a disaster
because travel between states is
constitutionally is it's a
constitutional right in the United
States ingress and egress from in two
states and when you look at the county
level map of the United States and you
see you know the red and orange counties
the ones that are in trouble they're
right next to counties that are doing
far better and so I believe that sadly
unless there are some interstate travel
restrictions put in place which I'm
neither recommending nor do I believe
would necessarily be legal I merely
making a sort of mathematical statement
you're going to see some of the states
that are doing well start to do less
well if cases continue to skyrocket in
places like Florida Arizona California
Texas and many others I can't even give
you the full list now I I do think also
that there are some governor's including
our governor here I believe Charlie
Baker here in Massachusetts has widely
done a very good job and what I'm
worried about is they're now doing the
indoor dining in Massachusetts I got a
message from my gym that its opening
next Monday I think that this is a
mistake we've done so much work here for
the last four months to get down to only
having a couple hundred new cases a day
without a spike it's like every day
about 200 cases 200 cases it seems to me
given that it's summer given that people
can do outdoor dining given that people
can do outdoor workouts I understand the
business side of it it seems too risky
to me to do indoor dining or to open
gyms movie theaters and some of the
other things being discussed I won't be
partaking I've been doing the outdoor
dining it feels safe it's more than
enough it's warm out I think that that's
a risk for the states that are doing
well to do right now and I hope that I'm
wrong but the numbers are truly truly
scary